oh
my god so i just caught up on one punch
man and i don't even really know what to
say right now my mind is still
physically recovering after the ethereal
level abuse that it's just been dealt
the assault that morata has played on my
senses has left me partially freaking
disintegrated and slumped in my chair
but like the true freaking degenerate i
am and just like dingy with mahima i'm
literally begging for more this fight is
the greatest thing i have ever read in
terms of just pure hype unrealistically
good art and a satisfying freaking
ending to the battle which is something
i'm always extremely grateful for these
days but of course if you guys are new
around here and want to see more stuff
just like this once a week where i go
over whole arcs fights or just entire
stories in way too much detail then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to let me know what series
or fights you want me to cover in the
future but anyway just a quick recap of
what's happened in the moments leading
up to this climactic battle right here
because it's literally insane i'm not
going to go over everything because
obviously this fight or these fights
with this monster association arc have
been going on for the last like 70
chapters or so but in the moments
leading up to this moment right here
like it's actually insane how good this
fight is the hero who i constantly dig
on for being overrated and just ass in
the first place pig god showed his true
potential by doing the most insane eco
play of his entire life and swallowed
all of the heroes who were around the
battlefield just moments before they
were killed like this guy literally
flies through a tsunami of water and
swallows everyone it's you know it's
just so freaking insane with all of the
heroes safe inside of pig god and after
garrow defeats the freaking monolith
that is the sage centipede you know by
the way if you want me to cover this
entire arc or the entire one punch man
story in general from the moment like
the anime ended then smash that like
button to 5k likes and i'll make sure to
get it done before the end of the year
anyway anyway enough of me creaming over
the story but back with garrow after he
lays out the scenes of peed he observes
the surroundings and doesn't notice any
s-class heroes he comes to the
conclusion that they have all been taken
down and that it is time for him to
reach his ultimate goal to become
absolute evil
however as he's wondering what happened
to the evil ocean water monster a sudden
feeling of anxiety comes across him to
gary's surprise saitama lands behind him
and asks what he's supposed to be
although garrow at this point doesn't
realize saitama's actual identity he
still answers the bald king's question
regarding what he is by stating that he
is a monster who will cast all of
humanity into the depths of a despair
and become absolute evil
saitama is confused though about whether
garrow is evil considering he helped a
helicopter escape from the sage
centipede just before the garrow reasons
that he needs witnesses to spread fear
and to let people know that he is
stronger than any hero or monster
stating their absolute evil correlates
with absolute strength gary then tells
saitama to leave and quit his job as he
will annihilate both the monster and
hero association he then and our typical
evil villain stereotype rambles on about
his plans of utter domination after
listening to garo saitama begins to
leave without acknowledging him as a
monster which leaves he jacked up cairo
just utterly confused frustrated saitama
explains to him that the only reason he
is out here in the first place is
because he went out of his way to
complain about the noise and now because
of that his house has been completely
destroyed due to this random set of
circumstances in saitama's eyes he's
extremely upset and says that now he
would rather blow up the entire planet
making garrow shiver with his words as
saitama leaves garrow calls out to him
saying he'll pay should he underestimate
absolute evil and charges adam will they
punch unfortunately for him saitama is
just frankly unbeatable and with an
impulsive punch he knocks garrow back
before the latter could land the hurts
after being punched garu manages to
remember saitama identifying him as the
one bald guy that he's run into several
times before which is obviously just
hilarious to me i love how like all the
past scuffles or interactions i don't
know really what you would call them
between like garrow and saitama have
just been garrow getting completely and
utterly abused by an unaware side hammer
like it's just just too good anyway
anyway now the main battle can begin
asgaro finally realizes who this goat of
a baldi truly is
now having recovered from saitama's
punch garrop appears to properly begin
fighting him they begin exchanging blows
while crossing kilometers and just
moments reaching far into the upper
atmosphere of the sky saitama attacks
garrow with a punch aimed at his head
but garrow now having literally ascended
manages to dodge it before axe kicking
our baldi into the ground causing a huge
section of land mass to instantly
rupture sending rubble shooting out when
saitama stands up onto his feet garrow
leaps down towards him with a hand chop
striking his head directly causing a
forceful impact on the surroundings
however the hand chop is not enough to
phase our boy who retaliates with a
simple headbutt that shatters garrow's
forearm despite this garrow manages to
regenerate his forearm and attempts to
punch saitama however the caped body is
faster and manages to punch him back
first after being knocked back a
considerable distance by saitama
garrow's body in response to his anger
undergoes a mutation that increases his
size and stature as well as his strength
at this moment tario remember that like
little wave of a kid who was a mad hero
fan had the whole book and all well like
now he's just a mad garrow fanboy at
this point in the stories which is like
dopano because like so is everyone else
obviously but anyway anyway just before
this point somehow he had managed to
evade all of the other heroes trying to
flee and made his way up behind the
bulked-up demonic gyro he then tells him
that he is a hero to him which annoys
garrow who tries to explain again to
tario that he is not a hero at all
yet even after what garrosh says the boy
still insists that he is the greatest
hero to him and tells garrow to stop
pretending to be a monster
saitama slowly comes up to the two of
them and comments on the terrible things
garrow has done like murking heroes
crushing dojos and now playing monster
causing this innocent kid to break down
and cry as saitama takes his steps
towards the hero hunter tario tries to
stop him from further fighting the hero
however garrow still lays out saitama
and punches him hard in the head after
getting provoked though as per usual
saitama is completely unscathed even
after taking their punch head on he then
boldly and like the true chad level bald
king he is reassures a shock tario that
garrow will not be able to hurt him
angered garrow tries to kick saitama but
is immediately slapped away by the hero
as if it was nothing back with tario
saitama asks him if he'd like him to
stop but not kill garrow and return him
to normal to which garrow solemnly nods
in agreement which is like so damn
wholesome man i love seeing these little
bits of like actual human moments from
our psychotic little baldy it just goes
to show that he still has a bit of heart
left in him somewhere so finally it's
just a two big bad boy standing there
inside him a question is why garo is
acting like a monster despite previously
having helped heroes garrow tries to
reason that he was merely using them to
further his goals of absolute evil yet
after saitama casually lumps garrow's
absolute evil together with world peace
in a randomly coincidental way gero
angrily charges at him he manages to
parry a punch from saitama then using
the momentum he hand chops him right in
the side of his face and lands a punch
to his head before elbowing him in his
stomach all done within the fraction of
a second when saitama grabs guru's arm
the enlightened hero hunter performed
several lock-on moves that eventually
hit saitama in the hip garo instantly
follows up and proceeds to use his god
slayer instant attack slamming his foe
into the ground with a flurry of
monstrous punches however saitama having
evaded the attack soon emerges nearby
after digging underground and throws a
massive rocket garrow while asking the
hero hunter if he's able to avoid his
punches due to his special martial arts
skills to which garrow confirms while
shattering the rock with his freaking
jointless rotating arms garrow attempts
a barrage of attacks on saitama but the
hero manages to dodge prompting him to
remark that saitama has amazing reflexes
and agility but still that skill and has
plenty of openings which is just
hilarious like garro bro you need to
focus on yourself first claiming to be
able to read all of saitama's moves now
big brain garrow declares that the hero
will lose due to his lack of technique
and being a complete amateur before
sending him absolutely flying and
crashing into several buildings with his
god slayer ascending attack instantly
after this like just unfathomable faked
garrow catches right up to saitama and
uses his great fujin which like i hope i
got right and didn't mess it up like
because this attack is just absolutely
insane i'm gonna be calling out the art
for this entire video because it's just
freaking gods here at this point like
look at it the buildings lift up and
they slam together like it's so so good
and believe me this is just the freaking
beginning of the stuff this great fujin
seems the big boulder crashing through
more buildings lifting them up off the
ground and ultimately pulverizing them
into nothing but dust and smoke
believing here is one now garrosh states
that saitama may have incredibly tough
skin and bones but he cannot train his
internal organs which garrow believes to
have been damaged by his attack however
to his surprise saitama emerges
completely unharmed it is then shown
that garrow and destroying the buildings
and following in the way of absolute
evil has accidentally saved five hero
association staff members who had been
trapped inside an underground shelter as
all of them show their gratitude to him
before leaving saitama ironically
comments on how absolute evil is
actually good at saving people enraged
that he just ain't evil enough yet garu
attacks saitama again and soon evolves
even further taking on the sick as [__]
demonic type form that has these almost
unproportionate looking wings on his
back but it's honestly still fires while
defending against an onslaught from him
saitama states that garrow has improved
a little which angus the hero hunter who
with a punch knocks him into a currently
exploding volcano garrow immediately
charges at saitama and strikes him with
both of his open palms causing the
mountain behind to shatter due to the
powerful impact after the attack garrow
was on his knees and panting while an
unharmed saitama simply punches him away
recovering his balance gara was
impressed that saitama could withstand
the attack that destroyed the volcano
behind him also hilariously following in
the current course of things garrow has
accidentally saved an entire city from
being destroyed by the volcano's lava
and again saitama notices this random
act of so-called kindness and almost
taunts him commenting that garrow has a
great hero's instinct which reminds him
a lot of king
guerra crews two more arms and continues
his onslaught however he is now visibly
showing signs of panic as he fights back
against our baldi ps shout out to all
your bald kings out there like get this
video to 50k likes i honestly don't even
know why i'm saying this right now which
is honestly unachievable for me and i'll
go bold like [__] it man i'll go like
hell why not i'll do it for do it for
100k subs and if this video gets the 50k
likes i'll do it because how saitama is
a goat man and i love this arc so much
i've had so much fun reading it despite
being attacked by the hero hunter who is
using all four of his arms saitama
effortlessly manages to dodge and
parries a flurry of garo's punches with
only one hand while also telling him to
just straight up stop fighting which is
a freaking insane burn on a man
afterwards garrow places two of his
hands on saitama and takes a form that
resembles a jet while his remaining two
arms emits energy to act as propulsion
helium follows up with a mighty attack
called extreme fajin garrow pushes
saitama into the ground creating an
intense seismic wave that passes
directly through the earth's core the
attack is so freaking immensely powerful
that it distorts the space time around
the earth moves oceanic plates and even
makes an entire continent raise up from
the other side of the planet it even
messes with the magnetic and
gravitational fields of the planet
putting it as a whole at risk despite
all of its efforts saitama is still
unfazed by garrow's earth altering
attack and retaliates with its infamous
consecutive normal punches as the two of
them return from earth's depths garrow
tries to fend off saitama's flurry of
punches but fails at this moment he
recalls the abominable fist sage
centipede had once mentioned and deduces
that he was referring to saitama instead
of garrow himself our bald king proceeds
to punch garrow directly in the face
snapping him back to reality while
causing him to crash through several
mountains and eventually fall into a
massive puddle as he slowly gets back up
garrow was shocked and angered by
saitama's overwhelming power viewing him
as the embodiment of unfairness which
like he literally is like i'm sorry goku
fans but this is why saitama is
unbeatable like full stop the dude is
created to never lose in the first place
goku has lost the guys even freaking
died saitama is literally god at this
point his insanity incarnate it's like
utterly beautiful and unstoppable i
freaking love it man because of this
gero charges that saitama will they
punch refusing to lose to him however
saitama punches gyaro before he can
himself and seems him flying away
destroying garrow's monster form and
exposing his true human body that had
been buried inside his monster's
exoskeleton as garo laments being beaten
by such unfairness he hears a voice
calling out to him the voice tells him
that there is only one fist that can
counter the fist that is turned against
god everyone's favorite villain then
sees an aberration of bang hovering
above him and offering garrow his hand
at the same time massive storm clouds
appear revealing like i don't even know
what to call this thing like god's legs
or something all we know is this
creature is a 100 on leg day right now
anyway with everyone witnessing this
saitama ominously knows that something
is coming
in that moment he sees garrow leap down
from behind to face him once again
scitomatic exclaims that garrow changed
costumes again while garrow having
received the power from the one they
call god replies that the only way to
counter the fist that is turned against
god is the fist of god itself
like oh my god this form is so freaking
clean like mirada you need to chill man
i'm actually gonna uh anyway anyway now
appearing as a void of stars and
galaxies and as new awakened garrow
cosmic fear mode he takes a fighting
start and prepares for another round
against the one and only invincible hero
having now gained the knowledge of all
of the flow of energy that courses
through the universe as well as the
behavior of the forces of the cosmos
gary utilizes said flow of energy to
send a cataclysmic attack towards
saitama called the life eradication
first mark nuclear fission the attack
results in a massive nuclear explosion
which is instantly followed by several
more that reach up into the sky as
garrow continues attack while the
surviving heroes including psychos who
has emerged since her defeat at the
hands of tatsumaki stare in amazement
and horror at the nuclear blasts
exploding nearby well anyway i think
it's kind of sad for our heroes down
below guys time for the radiation
poisoning big rip on them all down there
the heroes below watch the battle
between saitama and garrow which is
obscured by mountainous clouds from
garrow's attacks leaving only their
silhouettes briefly visible through
flashes of power
despite the enormous force behind the
attacks saitama was much more concerned
over his outfit which leaves garrow
utterly bewildered nevertheless garupa
claims that he feels like he can do
anything before explaining to saitama
that in martial arts there are secret
techniques known as shakai where martial
artists can borrow the power of nature
by imitating the movement of living
things garrow prefers to address them as
modes since to him they sound cool that
way he then demonstrates one of these
modes that being mo saitama as saitama's
own face appears in place of garrow's
featureless void-like face garrow
duplicates and utilizes saitama's
consecutive normal punches assaulting
the hero with his own technique
prompting saitama to respond with his
own consecutive normal punches honestly
this is somehow just the beginning of
the true insanity which is about to come
like hold on to your damn seats because
we're going far out of this freaking
world their fists collide an exchange of
blows creating an enormous destructive
force that pushes out around them
destroying everything in its path the
exchange of blows ends with saitama and
garrow simultaneously landing a blow to
one another's faces sending them both
directly into the water below instantly
they both leaked back out of the water
with garu then taunting saitama on how
he must be at a loss for word upon
finding someone who could finally match
his strength
saitama though is slightly dismayed as
he thinks back to how he promised tario
he wouldn't get scratched seeing this
and fairly empowered garrow goes to show
tario how powerless heroes truly are he
begins to charge his body as it is
encased in a singularity before
unleashing another extremely powerful
attack called the life eradication fist
mark gamma ray burst towards saitama
okay okay okay like i'm just going to
physically break open the power scaling
world for one punch man like right here
so this gamma ray burst is literally
like one of the most powerful phenomena
in existence like
we get this in our own reality we have
evidence earth was hit by one during the
7th century a.d but it was only like a
little bit of gamma radiation people
wouldn't have noticed it back then and
it was like around 4 000 light years
away from earth which is an unfathomable
amount of distance if this gamma-ray
burst happened within a few light years
or even a few hundred light years which
is like by the way still an unfathomable
distance it would rip apart our
atmosphere like instantly and
subsequently kill all life on the
freaking planet now get this okay like
like get this this gamma-ray burst is on
the surface of this freaking planet with
people right next to it like they should
be vaporized instantaneously along with
the planet like they shouldn't even be
there nothing should be there as soon as
that ability goes out but like the fact
they're even there right now makes them
naturally the strongest people and the
strongest soil in existence like an
anime full stop like show me another
damn series where a plain a grey type
hero is able to stand next to a force
that would kill all life within a
fraction of a second if it happened at
the moon's distance from our own earth
anyway anyway i've rambled on for too
long i'm just nerdy as [__] for that
science stuff i absolutely love it now
saitama realizes that if any attack
grazes the ground it will destroy the
planet so in an attempt to save it he
decides to jump high into the air to
bring the attack away from the ground
however garrow thinks he is attempting
to dodge it by jumping because of this
the attack directly hits and completely
engulfs saitama in a beam of the
universe's highest level radiation
sending him off the planet at literally
the speed of light itself if not faster
because that is literally the speeds we
are talking about here when a gamma
gamma-ray burst goes off man's ability
can technically go faster than light
itself now with a big baldy literally
shot into the abyss of space gary lands
on a pile of debris and confronts the
various heroes of the hero association
that have huddled around together their
remaining heroes immediately realized
that the man standing before them was
the source of this massive energy
explosion just moments before only the
s-class heroes remain on the spot while
the lower ranks begin to run away in
fear
seeing this garrow questions if he has
finally achieved his ultimate goal of
becoming absolute evil grateful for the
strength he had received garrow looks
into the sky and ominously says thank
you
bang being one of the heroes who chose
to stay rather than run away confronts
garrow and asks if a monster did
something to him garrow then reveals to
bang that he wasn't truly tricked by the
entity that approached him earlier and
instead knew all along that the strange
figure who took the form of bang wasn't
actually his former master regardless
garrow was informed that simply coming
into contact with the entity was enough
for him to be greatly influenced by it
however garrett denies that he has
become a puppet and states that what he
is doing is of his own free will after
making this clear to everyone gary
decides that it is now time to conduct
evil as garrow approaches the remaining
heroes child emperor and wagen ma start
to bleed from their noses moments later
the two children collapsed onto the
ground seemingly dead to the effects of
garrow's radiation
despite garu stating that he is in
control of his own actions bang still
believes that there is something evil
within garrow and that that evil is now
controlling him
suddenly oh yes man the big man himself
rank one s-class hero blast randomly
teleports into the area and introduces
himself to a surprised gero he attempts
to reason with garrow stating that he
has been controlled by a mysterious
entity known as god and emphasizes that
in garrow's current form any attack
unleashed would endanger all life on
earth although garrow still retains his
careless demeanor he is somewhat
intrigued by what blast has just said
and asks what he should do about it
blast offers the transport garrow into
another dimension but the awakened
garrow simply declines the offer and
instead boasts about how his mere
presence is now causing people to die
believing that he has finally become the
true symbol of fear
bang attempts to stop garrow from
proceeding but suddenly genos who's
literally nothing but a damn torso at
the moment uses the remaining bits of
power he has left and hurls himself
towards the seemingly invincible enemy
and headbutts him in the chair stating
that there is another radiation
resistant hero he forgot about however
though garrow easily grabs the hero by
the hair and goes to finish him off but
before he can do anything blast
intervenes and begins to fight garrow
off himself
blast fires has dimensioned cannon
towards garrow but the hero hunter
quickly dodges the blast well commenting
it to be a lame attack which is you know
kind of funny because of the hype around
blast you'd expect him to have these
insane abilities but he's just got like
these boxing gloves pretty much however
a portal appears above garrow and
transports him to where blast is
followed by a powerful punch from blast
called the gravity knuckle straight to
garrow's face forcing him to release
genos blast summons another portal to
where garrow is and redirects his
trajectory to have a mate yet another
punch straight to the face blast
continues this pattern as he rapidly
pummels garrow in the face all the while
slowly bringing his portals closer
together before long blast quickly seals
the two portals with the intent of
sealing garrow within another dimension
however much the blast's shock garrow
emerges from a portal of his own making
having mimicked blasts own powers and
techniques he now wields blasts gravity
knuckle in his right hand and his own
life eradication fist mark nuclear
fission and the other he uses both of
these to unleash a rapid barrage of
attacks on blast doing his best to try
and overwhelm the number one hero this
forces blast on the defensive as he
summons multiple teleportation rings to
redirect garrow's attacks elsewhere
another portal is then summoned by blast
above the sky which absorbs the
remaining explosions in order to prevent
further destruction to the environment
nonetheless the utter force of the
attack sends both garrow and blast
shooting away from each other noting the
extreme energy being put off blast fears
that if this battle continues for much
longer then not only will the gates that
seemingly keep god at bay weekend but
everything only planet will die from the
radiation garrow is a methane which by
the way are like i'm hella curious as to
what these gates could be and how like
the hell can we even get to a bigger
level of power from this point like oh
my lord garrick means blast as he sees
that he's not the number one hero for
nothing but also immediately realizes
something else and decides to shift his
focus back onto saitama realizing that
the bald king will soon return and that
the hero was not going all out while
fighting earlier gary decides to kill
genos in order to draw out the full
power of saitama garrow then probably
the most heart-wrenching moment in the
entire series so far impales genos
through the chest and rips out his core
only a second or two later asgaro holds
his heart in his hands saitama finally
returns back to earth
as he stands there and pure bewilderment
and shock a black liquid slowly begins
to pour down like rain due to the
nuclear fallout seeing his deadpan
expression garu taunts him by throwing
genesis depleted core adam saitama
catches it and stares blankly
remembering genos previous words about
how he is always on time denying them by
stating that he is usually always late
saitama enraged and with a serious
expression on his face unleashes his
first serious punch towards garrow who
immediately responds with a serious
punch of his own having copied saitama
once again using mode saitama blast
immediately and fearfully realizes that
the fallout from the two colliding
attacks will completely destroy the
earth in an attempt to try and save the
planet he summons a portal beneath the
two and just as their fists collide they
are transported away up into space above
the upper atmosphere of the earth
however the kinetic energy that erupted
from the serious punch squared was so
powerful that blast's dimensional gate
was unable to sustain it as blast comes
to the realization that he may be unable
to angle the vector of energy away from
earth three of blasts allies come to us
aid which honestly cracks me up man like
who are these space la who are these
space arse looking ranger games no i
love the universe expansion stuff for
the next arc and so forth
it's great i can't wait to see like more
of this kind of [__] anyway with all
four of them there they are able to
create an opening inside of the barrier
that launches saitama and garu 43 light
minutes away from the earth while the
shock wave of energy itself is directed
in the completely opposite direction
which results in the destruction of like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
numerous star systems seen in the night
sky which is like literally mental i
don't know where this beam went but it
was probably faster than light itself
and it's probably gone and out damn
galaxy by now okay so the final real
battle properly begins now like you guys
this is it this is the end we're getting
the very end part of the battle this is
insanity incarnate saitama and garrow
crash into a celestial satellite
revealed to be low one of jupiter's
moons the two were initially bewildered
and confused but after figuring out
their location saitama stands above
garrow atop a small hill and proclaims
that he can finally let loose against
someone who can finally withstand his
full power yet despite that fact he
still doesn't feel the least bit excited
to finally go all out garrow still
annoyed with the current location
suggests that they should find a way to
get back to earth but saitama instantly
shuts him down and says that they will
need to figure it out after he defeats
them stating that he only needs one hand
to do so unfazed garo initiates the
fight once more by simply summoning a
portal beneath saitama only for the
caped body to casually kick it away much
to garu surprise then suddenly in an
instant garu is rocked by a punch from
saitama sending him flying off the moon
garrow quickly creates a portal that
brings him back to saitama and attempts
to counter where they punch only for
saitama to flip garrow's portal upside
down thus making garrow hit the air
instead before he is then thumped by yet
another punch that sends him rocketing
into the floor unimpressed saito tells
garrow to stop using his cosmic tricks
and fight him with his fists going on to
taunt him asking if these attacks are so
called ultimate martial arts again with
the martial arts garrow offended by his
taunt obliges while saying he has
absorbed countless martial arts and
techniques before he dashes around
saitama with a mint speed through
multiple portals in an attempt to
disorientate him he first attacks him
with roaring or a sky-ripping fist then
deflects a punch from saitama with water
streaming rock smashing fist before
sending the hero flying with exploding
hearts released fist followed by
whirlwind iron cutting fist then finally
ending the combo with nuclear fission
gravity knuckle that creates a massive
atomic explosion which is then absorbed
into a singularity by the gravity
knuckle standing amidst the smoke gary
declares that his fists are unavoidable
and that timing is irrelevant regarding
his attacks but to his shock saitama
once again emerges completely unscathed
say for obviously being completely naked
this time as his costume was completely
and utterly destroyed from garrow's
attacks and as he stands there he
replies to the hunter that he can do
something very similar okay this here is
going to blow your freaking minds i
don't even i don't even know why i keep
saying this it's just all going to blow
your mind it's like oh my god mirada
just stop man with the god here ah
when i read these set of pages for the
first time while i actually collapsed oh
this is my favorite set of panels i've
ever seen this scale is utterly unreal
and i've never seen anything betray just
how mental this is in such a brilliant
and perfect way so sit back as we all
prepare our little monkey brains our
bold king the god himself demonstrates
this by digging his fingers into the
ground with one hand
like let me remind you with one hand and
unleashes a new attack called serious
table flip before flipping massive
amounts of the moon's crust thousands of
meters up into the air taking garrow
with it the attack then utterly
decimates the entirety of the freaking
moon itself unraveling it like an orange
peel or while garrow aimlessly and
helplessly hurdles high into the air
amongst the innumerable number of debris
suddenly saitama dashes around garrow
with incredible speed crashing hundreds
of after-images in the process before he
directs his after images and himself
towards garrow simultaneously with
another serious series called
omnidirectional serious punch garrow
instantly avoids the attack by jumping
into a portal only to see much to his
horror that saitama is already directly
below him within his own portal he had
just freaking open and proceeds to punch
him with a serious punch as the hit
lands it sends garrow flying and
ricocheting off these slabs of stone
only for saitama to follow up once again
and punch him away as he is about to hit
another slab saitama dashes around
garrow back and forth with a measurable
speed or while punching him across the
entirety of the demolished surface of
the moon creating a full-on geometric
surface of light from the intensity of
the attacks garrow then furiously repels
saitama's flurry of attacks with his
water stream rock smashing fist and
lands on a large slab of debris garrow
attempts to regain his composure while
needing to find a way to get above the
rocks he creates a portal only to have
his head smashed into another slab of
rock stunned garrow realizes that
saitama's attack had completely warped
his sense of direction and now he
utterly feels like a caged insect being
played with by a child before he could
react he's suddenly attacked by another
serious punch from saitama garrow is
aghast by saitama's limitless strength
but remains steadfast and declares that
if he is to win against him then he will
need to continuously replicate his power
and technique until he achieves victory
as he does this he once again enters
mode saitama before he and the caped
body both punch each other directly in
the face the battle continues as garrow
throws a punch through a hyper space
portal that reaches saitama on the other
end only for saitama to quickly
retaliate with a punch of his own
instantly as he is sent hurling
backwards from saitama's punch garrow
creates another portal behind him that
redirects him behind saitama and uses
his momentum to unleash an axe kick onto
saitama's head only for the letter to
simultaneously counter where they punch
to garo's guards the punch scenes go
back into the portal with the hero
hunter then opening another portal and
swiping back at saitama only to miss as
our bold king jumps backwards he lands
onto a large slab of debris then leaps
downwards with such an immense force
that it destroys the slab and follows
with a monstrous karate chop straight to
garrow's neck which in turn devastates
the surrounding area around them the
fight escalates as they move and dash
about the decimated moon in an exchange
of vicious blows garrow is bewelded at
the fact that despite countering him
with just as much power saisoma simply
responds with even greater force than
before and yet i remind you again with
just one hand as well as garrow performs
a powerful punch to saitama's gut the
latter doesn't flinch encounters with an
uppercut that sends garrow flying into
the air it is then explained through
this shocked garrow that saitama's
growth in power and strength
continuously rises at an exponential
rate with his own strength struggling to
keep up leading him to realize that at
this rate he could actually die from one
of saitama's punches saitama shrinks
soars due to an upsurge of emotion from
him trying to kill genos earlier garrow
now slowly falling behind dashes around
with incredible speed preparing for an
attack
saitama meanwhile only realizes that now
his costume had been completely blown
off and it actually started to get cold
an enraged garrow attempts to throw a
punch at saitama but the bald king
casually grabs it without even looking
due to the cold saitama was about to
sneeze which forces garrow to
instinctively evade and honestly he's
goddamn lucky he chose to as saitama
unleashes a serious sneeze that not only
parts a large portion of the moon's
floating debris but also actually
annihilates and clears an enormous mass
of jupiter's atmosphere and weather
system revealing the small supposedly
solid surface of the planet like this is
actually so insane the utter mass that
is on that planet is ridiculous in
actual reality we don't even know if
this surface exists we haven't even had
to get something down there i have no
idea how to even scale the force of this
ability like it's so freaking
unfathomable to me it's that insane the
display of power leaves garrow in shock
all the while they rocket away from the
moan and jupiter due to the force of
saitama's sneeze as they saw through
space garrow notices the sun then used
in his enhanced vision and perception he
is able to make it a clear vision of the
earth which allows him to teleport there
just before doing so in an attempt to
escape he threw a nuclear fission punch
directly at saitama giving him the
opportunity to escape and finally return
to earth via his portal after escaping
garrow celebrates his return and
presumed victory only to instantly
discover to his horror that saitama was
already right behind him complimenting
his last move bewildered garrow
questioned saitama on how he managed to
return to which saitama replies by
saying that the coldness of space had
given him such a stomach ache and while
he was initially holding it in garrow's
last attack surprised him and made him
literally [__] himself back through
garrow's portal as the fight now kicks
back off saitama punches garrosh
directly in the face and sends thee to
rocketing back down towards earth's
surface as they crash land our bodies
punch shatters garo's mode saitama
leaving him with his normal human face
now appearing battered and bruised
seemingly defeated now garrow asks why
saitama won't kill him our hero responds
that it is because he is a hero and in
addition to that it was also tario's
final request to stop him without
killing him garrow pauses when he hears
the words final request
and sadly as he looks over to his side
he sees tario's dead body who would
succumb to the radiation earlier on garu
screams and utter despair but quickly
attempts to run away upon realising that
he was too close to tario but stumbles
and falls to the ground
seeing tario's dead body as well as the
earth's desolate landscape garu soro
fully realised that he indeed is that
ominous future
saitama standing there only wonders why
garrow has been acting so strange ever
since he first appeared in his cosmic
fear mode which you know for those who
are confused is like the moment that the
god bang mofo showed up and gave him
some power i guess curious saitama asks
if someone truly did make him the way he
is now but gareth only solemnly replies
that if that is the case then it was
because his spirit was weak
i honestly love garrosh character
development throughout this fight and
just the series in general it's really
really really really good and i
recommend anyone just to go back and
read the entire point from the moment he
comes in because he's like the main
character from that moment to like
probably right up to now
garrow continues to despair as he sees
that if he cannot beat saitama then he
can never truly become absolute evil
even so gara would have been satisfied
if saitama killed him the way he
envisioned heroes killed all of their
villains and that way his legacy of
being true evil would linger onward
moreover he only meant to save the likes
of tario with his ideals but saitama
cuts him off and says that garo only
clung to tario for support gareth was
prepared to angrily retort but upon
seeing that saitama was still holding on
to genesis core he realised that even
him with all of his insane power and
strength still needs something that
would help him hold on to reality and
keep fighting when saitama asks scarrow
what he's going to do now garu somberly
asks saitama for a favor
the favor involves garrow wanting
saitama to copy his martial art knowing
that saitama will be able to use them to
their fullest potential while there's
limitless power
gary will pass on his most powerful
martial arts technique which he has not
performed even with god's power at his
disposal so i guess with all of my
maiming on like the martial arts it's a
cheeky one that saves the day saitama
then agrees and gareth appears to
transfer his ultimate technique to
saitama as he knows that he would be the
only person able to resist god using its
own power
suddenly the one they call god silence
his garrow and begins to siphon his
power and life which subsequently begins
to make garrow's body break down into
salt which is like kind of random man
like why salt as garrow fully transfers
the cosmic rays within himself into
saitama he says his final words to the
caped baldi stating that he is the only
one who can truly defeat the impending
ominous future that is wasting him
before he fully perishes and his body
crumbles into salt okay takamichi please
sit down now we got saitama time
travelling back for his bestie as time
travels backwards in time saitama sees
all of the instances of their battle and
is left in utter amazement at the beauty
of garrow's technique when he spots the
moment when garrow declares himself as
that ominous future to the heroes of the
hero association saitama takes this as
his cue and punches through it
back in reality asgaro looks at the sky
thanking the god that had just given him
the strength randomly and literally out
of freaking nowhere saitama appears and
thumps garrow with an infinitely strong
hook to his freaking dome it's explained
that because of the insanity of the
training saitama's punch underwent on
the moon it had gifted him the ability
to technically reverse time and thus
land his strike before it even released
and reverse causality is impossible to
dodge thus it was not one punch that
decided to fight
no
it was a zero punch
as the present heroes watch in amazement
a shocked garrow realizes that his power
is beginning to escape his wounded body
so yeah like if anyone is like how the
[__] is he able to go from not dying
from one of saitama's attacks to just
randomly dying from like a punch
obviously it was the infamous zero punch
where he literally like reversed time
with it and everything but pretty much
saitama is just like physically
something else now like he's way past
garrow before his moon buff so you can
imagine what the saitama is like now
hitting garrow who doesn't even have
like the moon buff of strength from
growing like during the fight anyway the
future saitama is then instantly pulled
towards his past self and after they
make contact they become one with the
soul saitama now holding genesis core
from the future confused as to what
happened saitama only recalls being hit
by garo's gamma-ray burst which is kind
of sad i wish saitama kind of like
remembered everything or like somewhat
remembered everything but you'll see why
in a second as he looks down he is
initially shocked to see himself holding
the depleted core of his best boy genos
in his hands he instantly receives an
even greater surprise when he sees a
hole in his costume exactly in location
where his 12-inch king level size snake
is at suddenly out of nowhere and
following on the path of the fight that
had previously happened in the old
timeline zazama is rammed by genos as he
shoots through the ear the disciple
apologizes for getting carried away but
saitama is instead surprised to see him
still actually alive okay so that is the
end of the fight but i'm not gonna blue
balls here on the aftermath because for
some people that's you know like always
the best part getting to see you know
what happens to like people and
everything after the fight pretty much
garrow is back to his audio itself and
actually manages to escape away from all
of the heroes so it's super dope like
he's back to his normal human garrow
wanting to be monster dude and like all
that kind of stuff he's going to show up
probably from times to times and
accidentally save things which would be
like a funny gimmick i would say in the
future because you know that was like
this weird gimmick when that was him
before he got taken over by obviously
the one they call god and obviously he's
not going to rise up to the same state
he was before him because he knows
saitama is around and he will never be
able to beat saitama so it's like that's
just there in terms of does saitama know
what the [__] just happened and well
like yeah he does after after he gives
the quarter genos and plugs it in um
dennis reveals everything to him but
saitama it goes in one ear and out the
other as well you know like we all know
what silence is like but it's super
super like heartfelt in a way that we
get to see all of the insane feats and
everything are only kind of known
through genesis point of view as like
that was the whole point of the battle
was for saitama to like seek revenge
almost on him killing genos and for him
to like yeah save planet earth and
everything but he was trying to save his
boy you know like had to make sure he
defeated the villain so that he could
get back and plug in the guy's heart and
then this just happens to you know
happen because things get so out of hand
that i guess the only way to make sure
that the earth is like manageable to
like bring back to reality is literally
by reversing time they're still gonna
have massive like ruined thing like
there's gonna be radiation everywhere
that they have to clean up and there's a
new entire continent on the other side
of the planet that they forced out from
one of the attacks but yeah things like
their star systems missing and stuff
they still all exist in the future
because i'd imagine there's probably
people from those star systems that just
got instantly wiped out by this beam
that came out of nowhere
well that finally brings us to the very
end of this fight that is garrow the
sight armor obviously if you guys have
enjoyed the video and want to see more
stuff just like this in the future then
hit that subscribe button down below and
also be sure to hit that like button if
you want to see me lose my hair which
you know i highly doubt we're actually
going to hit 50 000 likes but if we do
then i will shave it off even in the
future i'll come back and shave it off
for a video or some random thing like
that obviously leave a comment down
below as well what kind of series and
all that kind of jazz you want me to go
over in the future i've got the two
jiu-jitsu guys and arcs that i'm going
to try and get out within the next like
kind of two weeks before i go away
anyway anyway anyway enough of it if you
guys do want to like support me more
then make sure to check out my patreon
which i will leave you know down in the
description below and thank you to all
of my patreons who have been supporting
me for the last like almost nine months
now since i made you know like my
patreon back then so thank you so much
for all of the support from everyone in
general and thank you for 85 000 subs
i'm pretty sure like we're either about
to hit it today or we hit it already the
growth has been like phenomenal with
like obviously chainsaw man and that
almost coming out now we've got a little
bit to go but you know i can't wait till
that does get out but yeah thank you for
that as well but for now it's been a
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in there